[Música]
bom dia bom dia bom meu nome é pedro
praia
eu sou cantor de nascença músico
purificação é desde cedo possível o que
eu queria fazer da minha vida eu ia ter
a melhor profissão do mundo ia ser
músico isso muitos menores de 7 anos que
sai por ficar em bairros mais tarde fui
um dos fundadores de uma banda que chama
os limites da avó
hoje praticamente todos os níveis meu
filho está aí aos mais pressa em
contradizer isso não é bom
é nós gravamos dois álbuns na altura de
originais que vemos o país de lés a lés
durante dez anos quando a banda terminou
fui com o meu irmão o quarteto dos três
irmãos pedro e paulo
uma coisa do humor e canções que está
muito mais ligado ao mercado corporativo
em consequência disso criamos a 432 que
a nossa produtora produzidos conteúdos
de comunicação interna para empresas e
mais de 200 jatos essencialmente a
música como base a turma ia gastar fez
um balo eu uso necessário que essas
coisas e muita publicidade e mais
recentemente nasceu a pedra que é o meu
projeto canções originais onde eu quanto
a algumas histórias e através das
histórias cantar algumas canções e esse
que trouxe aqui hoje e que a organização
dessa tese é que teve a responsabilidade
de me convidar
bom mas eu vou tentar não desenvolvida
num fim de outubro norte eu peguei um
trem no tema do que este dia e para
deixar aqui uma é uma idéia e nina é uma
pergunta a um caminho certo haverá um
caminho certo
eu se for olhar pro meu o meu percurso
para o meu caminho que vem à distância é
uma série de equívocos e os 10 anos foi
estudar para um seminário para
infelicidade minha mãe não dá e padre
não seguir a vocação mas foi lá no
seminário que eu tomei contacto com
chendo com a música
mais tarde fui tirar um curso superior
de gestão atleta era porque eu tinha que
ter uma posição
ser músico mas sério eu não dei em
outubro mas por causa disso eu conheci
lá pessoas que eu sou hoje
importantíssimas para mim entre as quais
a mulher com quem viria a casar e que
desse casamento nasceu meu filho era um
casamento sagou num divórcio por causa
disso hoje ficou a marta que é o amor da
minha vida e que é melhor todos os dias
me ensina que há uma grande diferença
entre gostar de alguém e é mais alguém
mas isso daria pano pra manga para o
totó que não hoje
o amor também um bom tema nesta busca
deste norte
eu encontrei mais perguntas do que
respostas às perguntas que ocorreram foi
como é um cinto no meu caminho com que
eu estou a fazer nenhum propósito estou
convicto nesse propósito se há realmente
um verdadeiro norte se a um verdadeiro
caminho
o número também quer das falhas erros e
essas quedas
essas falhas erros não são igualmente
verdade
como eu disse agora sete anos a tocar e
no final dos anos 80 e início dos anos
90 os sexos as drogas e rock'n'roll
fizeram para tocar mais tarde percebi
que as drogas estavam a mais e já
estavam a prejudicar e decidi que tinha
de deixar de consumir ao isso continue
com sexo e rock'n'roll
é você troca já não fazia sentido já não
era problema o caminho e eu fiquei
contendo fiquei orgulhoso afinal momento
eu tomei uma decisão madura
finalmente uma decisão adulta finalmente
eu estou no caminho certo
a partir de agora nada de mal não vai
acontecer porque agora vai todo o
rebanho passar dois meses eu ter tomado
esta decisão porque a voz a voz é o
instrumento mais importante da minha
vida entre um estado de raiva angústia
de mesa e de uma injustiça tremenda
agora que o teu decisões certas agora
que eu estou no caminho certo
acontece que essa voz ganhe outro foi a
voz da consciência como disse que o fato
não deve queimar fichas durante muitos
anos e que agora estava a pagar o preço
eo preço garante que não foi um preço
barato e baixar os braços e rende ia
sair e foi aí que eu decidi que tinha
que aprender alguma coisa com este
problema que estava a acontecer
o leonardo cauã de uma canção deve ser
craque e navais em 10 ao dólar e às
quebras quilos diz permita entrar e foi
nesta silêncio desta solidão
nesta solidão deste silêncio que eu
encontrei alguma luz
foi aí que eu percebi que aprendia muito
mais ouvir do que falar foi o que eu
falei que eu percebi que minha estrada
nunca me larga
sou sempre eu o dono do meu caminho isso
o responsável por tornar esse caminho de
uma maldição ou uma bênção
só depende de mim e é sobre um pouco
essas coisas que a canção que eu vou
cantar fala e que chama sayed
é
epá lo para lá para onde o vôo
eu é que sair sai quem não fico cá isso
acabou aqui já me cansei chega ao fundo
as 500 escuridão ainda sobra alguém
domingo
olha aí de perto não é o fim
consigo respirar
[Música]
abra a porta parto da minha voz soprano
shendi
nada importa se a minha voz chegou a
doente
o som do silêncio espera para me abraçar
agora que até podia rir
estava decidido tudo e pardinho a pagar
[Música]
saio do
saio por fim
mais uma vez
mas esta vez saio do im
saio com
mas o
só estava
[Música]
da minha estrada
a vida voltou a que veio com medo pelo
seu pé
a escala que hoje sou in
daí no segredo que o meu forte é a fé
kawai bem fundo a sombra da solidão
souberem
muda a minha luz é mais brilha tudo isso
puxa a credicard
saio leão
saio por mim
i mais um mau
encha mas esta vem
eich saio
saio por fim
mais uma vez
eis o sol esta a minha estrada
[Música]
mas a estrada não
o lar gum
nem me deixam em afastar
maurição abençoada traz medo volta ao
meu lugar se preocupe saiu voltou a
entrar no sonho fim
saio
e saio por fim
[Música]
mas esta
sá
saio por fim
mais uma vez
sou está bem da minha estrada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
obrigado obrigado a loja o envio do zero
diz que eu tenho 148 4746 foi bom não
vou perder mais tempo têm um minuto para
terminar a minha top é o relógio que
prova que o tempo é o bem mais precioso
nós temos na vida
logo a vida também é um bem muito
precioso não tem hora para acabar
o toquinho que é um grande compositor
brasileiro escreveu numa das suas
canções dos kings
o futuro é uma astronave que tentamos
pilotar não tem tempo nem piedade nem
tem hora para chegar sem pedir licença
mudar nossa vida e depois convida a rir
ou chorar
quem está aqui sabe quanto tempo vai
demorar o seu futuro
quero aqui sabe o que vai fazer
realmente com ele nós temos a mania de
controlar um algoritmo extraordinário de
provas' quantidade futuro que existe
aqui um lado nesta sala e me interessa a
0 e terminar na altura da minha vida
consegue correr atrás e corridas de
longa e muito longa distância que durava
há muito tempo e nunca ninguém me deixou
uma busca da meta
toda a gente some do jogo boa prova
nós temos alguém que amamos e queremos
salvar a sua vida nós cantamos o que
muitas felicidades
nós tivemos uma boa vida que nós
queremos e não desejamos uma busca da
morte
tem graça não é quando eu o verão
passado fiz o que me incomoda com a
minha mulher
o caminho de santiago nunca ninguém
jogava bola chegar a santiago
somos já vão uma coisa bom caminho e é
sobre isto que esta próxima canção sobre
isso e mais algumas coisas que essa
próxima canção fala e canta e se aman
o que conta é o crime
o
quando a ponta do teu pé é tocada pelo
chão
fica só tom arrepio
tremo curação
[Música]
forças um sorriso em ser preciso para
não chorar
o primeiro passo nunca ninguém sabe
quando vai desaguar
[Música]
no princípio a viagem
é sempre um turbilhão traz o medo né
vagar sharing prenda a respiração
dizem que é normal passar pela sombra
passar pela dor
e depois olhar pra um lado o teu mundo
respirar melhor
pinta cada paz como um mago a ela traça
cada trás da virada tua tela junta novos
passos já não está sozinho
abraços abraços porque no final o que
conta é o caminho
[Música]
o
nada viva em linha reta
nem mesmo um foguetão qual o tempo pra
parar o largar o travão nem tinha piada
saber quantas voltas a vida vai dar
a não perder pitada em candal jurada a
chão para pisar
finta cada faro
como mágoa dela graça cada trás em davi
na tua tela
a junta novos passos já não está sozinho
abr a sós abraços porque no final o que
conta é o caminho
o que conta é o caminho
[Aplausos]
obrigado pra mim o que conta mesmo é o
caminho não fiquei pra ensinar nada fim
só que mesmo a falar de mim e e ele como
eu vejo meu caminho faz mais sentido
quando eu tenho as pessoas certas ao meu
lado e as pessoas certas são aquelas que
estão dispostas mesmo caminhar comigo
nos bons e nos péssimos nos maus
momentos e nem os mesmos crimes os
piores todos somos assim
é só mesmo os piores são assim tantos e
um filho nord sozinho é mais dura é mais
difícil do meu caso é impossível
e garante não tem piada nenhuma
tanto que olha norte e percebo porque é
que estou a fazer o meu caminho
olha sul para dentro de mim e sinto como
é que estou a fazer
olha é provavelmente o verdadeiro norte
é continuar a questionar todos estes
pontos cardiais se há um caminho incerto
desculpa eu não tenho uma resposta para
votar
sei que é um caminho que é errado é não
fazer caminho da obrigado
[Aplausos]